the console wars are never going to end
but the newest battle is over network
speed and reliability so between Xbox
Live and PlayStation Network which comes
out on top Microsoft has released an
independent study from IHS market
claiming Xbox Live is faster when
logging into the service and game
servers and playing uninterruptedly and
stay mccarthy commented on this and how
microsoft plans on continuing to improve
its service he said managing and
maintaining a network is complex and
there's an army of individuals who work
tirelessly on Xbox Live because at the
heart of it they're gamers just like you
our goal is to try and see bumps in the
road before they start or get through
them as smoothly as possible just know
that we have a team who works 24-7 to
optimize your gaming experience the IHS
market study was conducted in june and
july of this year using top selling
games with matchmaking support to make
its conclusions what do you think of the
findings you can let me know in the
comments or on twitter at chain-gun folk
and for all the latest xbox live and PSN
news you're already in the right place